hey 42 here in 1913 Hitler Stalin
Trotsky Tito and Freud all lived within
a few miles of each other
in Vienna with some of them being
regulars at the same coffee houses
welcome to RIF
the penalty for adultery in ancient
Greece involved hammering a radish into
the adulterers bottom with a mallet
radishes were a lot longer and pointy er
in those days by the age of 18 the
average American child will have seen
two hundred thousand murders on
television in 1672
an angry mob of Dutch men killed and ate
their prime minister McDonald's is one
of the largest owners of real estate in
the world and it turns the majority of
its profit from collecting rent not from
selling food Inuits use refrigerators to
stop their food from freezing in 2008
Usain Bolt set the world record for the
100 meters with one shoelace undone JK
Rowling author of the Harry Potter
series is the first person to become a
billionaire by writing books names of
Antarctic Islands include dissapointment
island fabulous islands desolation
Island monumental Island inexpressible
Island shag island circumcision island
and shoe island Iceland was once called
Waterland
because the grass was so rich it seems
to drip butter since 1700 new beetle
species have been discovered at the rate
of one every six hours when trying out a
new pen 97% of people will write their
own name first
a trained typists fingers covers about
16 miles a day
20% of all road accidents in Sweden
involve
an L every US president with a beard has
been Republican and finally 90% of
everything written in English uses just
1,000
words thanks for the view subscribe for
more 42